back here in this country house
impeachment managers accused the
president of believing he is above the
law as they lay out their argument that
the Senate should remove him from office
his Democratic accusers spoke for nearly
nine hours yesterday at the Senate
impeachment trial they argued the
president directed an effort to cheat in
the 2020 election and hold up military
aid to Ukraine the president and his
lawyers dismissed the Democrats
arguments which will continue today for
day two they insist mr. Trump has done
nothing wrong and will be acquitted
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill for us
where she listened to the testimony all
afternoon and into the evening Nancy
good morning so what do we expect from
day two good morning well they have been
trying to organize all of this evidence
into bite-sized pieces they'll continue
again today so categories like the
firing of the US ambassador or there was
holding of US aid to Ukraine as these
house managers try to convince the
Senate that the President himself was
behind an unethical scheme though it's
not clear they've changed any minds yet
the president went to extraordinary
lengths to cheat in the next election in
granular detail the seven impeachment
managers laid out all the ways the
president his aides and his lawyer
sought to pressure Ukraine the July 25th
call warrants are close scrutiny it
presents significant and shocking
evidence of president Trump's corrupt
intent I would like you to do us a favor
though these words will live in infamy
they also expressed frustration about
the evidence they were refused in the
State Department sending a first person
cable is an extraordinary step would you
like me to read that to you right now I
would like to read it to you right now
except I don't have it because the State
Department wouldn't provide it but if
you'd like me to read it to you we can
do something about that it all they
argued added up to abuse of power
warranting removal from office his
administration was quietly placing in a
legal hold and critical military aid to
support our friends
gratz called the arguments masterful
this presentation was one of the most
powerful court appearances that I have
ever seen many Republicans called it
repetitive president Trump is somehow
fixing to steal this next election I
think that's a crazy conspiracy theory
but really their whole case is built on
that and he came back to it over and
over and over the president's legal team
took notes from a nearby table readying
its defense for later this week we will
be putting on both an affirmative case
and in defense of the president but also
pointing out some of the errors in the
case that they presented Democrats are
still pushing for testimony from new
witnesses like former national security
advisor John Bolton ambassador Bolton
categorized the corrupt scheme the
pressure campaign as a quote drug deal I
think that ambassador Bolton was trying
to send send us a very powerful message
some Republicans say they're open to
witnesses if the Biden's testify to that
trade is is not on the table speaking to
voters in Iowa former Vice President Joe
Biden himself rejected the idea of a
witness swap saying that his testimony
would only turn the trial into political
theater Democrats have two more days for
arguments then the defense gets its shot
and clearly the President himself is
paying a great deal of attention because
he set a new record for tweets yesterday
142 of them including dozens on
impeachment his lawyers continued to
insist that he will be acquitted soon as
early as next week one week before his
State of the Union address the timing so
interesting he's certainly paying
attention thank you very much Nancy